our program helps students learn build
and get certified on Google cloud
platform the associate cloud engineer
track consists of the following benefits
first students and faculty receive a
hundred percent discount to pursue the
architecting with Google cloud platform
specialization on Coursera in addition
we are also making hands-on training
available in the form of self-paced labs
on quick labs here again there's a
hundred percent discount to access the
cloud architecture quest and other labs
finally we want both students and
faculty to prepare for certification to
prepare for and earn the associate cloud
engineer certification faculty who have
completed the specialization receive a
hundred percent discount on the
certification exam a student discount is
also available students who are familiar
with basic concepts related to operating
systems networking databases and
programming are good candidates for this
program what do you and your students
learn in the Associate cloud engineer
track the architecting with Google cloud
platform specialization on Coursera
comprises six courses the specialization
introduces learners to the comprehensive
and flexible infrastructure and platform
services provided by Google cloud
platform through a combination of
presentations demos and hands-on labs
learners explore and deploy solution
elements including infrastructure
components such as networks systems and
application services this course also
covers deploying practical solutions
including securely interconnecting
networks customer supplied encryption
keys security and access management
coders and billing and resource
monitoring
in the cloud architecture quest spanning
11 hours the labs have been curated to
give learners hands-on practice with
topics and services that appear in the
Associate cloud engineer certification
exam from I am to networking to
kubernetes engine deployment this quest
is composed of specific labs that will
put your GCP knowledge to the test in
addition to this quest learners also
have access to other labs the associate
cloud engineer track must be completed
in 16 weeks this slide shows a suggester
timeline complete the architecting with
Google cloud platform specialization
within the first nine weeks complete the
cloud architecture quest and additional
hands-on labs by week 16 complete the
associate cloud engineer certification
exam before the voucher expiration date
students can definitely race ahead of
the timeline learners completing the
architecting with Google cloud platform
specialization will earn a Coursera
completion certificate which can be
shared with prospective employers and a
professional network the associate cloud
engineer certification exam objectively
measures an individual's ability to
demonstrate the critical job skills
required for the role the exam duration
is two hours the format is multiple
choice and multiple select this exam
must be taken in person at one of our
testing center locations for more
details visit the associate cloud
engineer certification webpage some of
the faculty responsibilities are
registering for and attending online on
morning sessions enrolling and managing
students on your Coursera program
ideally your cohort has 60 to 200
students per faculty monitoring students
learning progress and nudging students
who may be falling behind
conducting study jams to support
students learning progress study jams
are essentially workshops that you
conduct with your students earning your
associate cloud engineer certification
and encouraging students to become
certified to validate technical
expertise for more information refer to
the faculty afaik use google cloud has
ensured that you as faculty are enabled
to run this program successfully in your
college or institution you get
administrative access on Coursera to
monitor students learning progress in
real-time the faculty Resource Center
provides enhanced support to faculty
with program related materials including
student FA cues and a guide on
conducting study jams your students will
also get access to a student Resource
Center faculty and students can contact
the Coursera and quick lab support teams
for any platform related issues